[Music]
we
sure love our roads we love them so much
that
we seem determined to pave the entire
world
but maybe roads can become the
future of renewable energy
that's right roads as energy generators
how by building them with solar panels
do we have the technology could we
power the entire world and
what are the drawbacks this
is what if and here's what would happen
if we
paved our roads with solar panels
[Music]
in 2017 the united kingdom
promised to run on 100 renewable energy
by 2025
[Music]
yet they still have a long way to go
with only 33
of their energy having come from
renewable sources in 2018
could solar panel roads be the answer
[Music]
energy is created when photons from the
sun
hit a silicon solar panel silicon is a
semiconductor and
has similar properties to metal and an
electrical insulator
so when the sun's photons hit the
silicon atoms in a solar cell
they transfer their energy to loose
electrons
which knocks them off the silicon atoms
this generates electricity
since the year 2000 there has been a 200
percent
increase in global renewable energy
consumption
sounds good for the solar industry
however
in 2019 of the 17
000 terawatt hours of renewable energy
created globally
only three percent came from solar
turning our abundance of roads into
energy creating
thoroughfares could move solar to the
fast lanes for renewable sources
[Music]
but how much solar road would we need
well in 2016 weywot
built a one kilometer solar roadway
it generated about 280 megawatt hours
per year
that's enough energy to power 25 homes
for
12 months the united kingdom has around
400 000 kilometers of road
if just 20 of those roads were converted
that would equal around 81 000
kilometers of
new solar panel paved roads the energy
from those roads
would only account for 5 of the uk's
total energy consumption in a year and
the price tag
well a one kilometer road in normandy
france
cost five million euro or approximately
five and a half million us dollars to
build and
that's enough to burn a sizeable hole in
a city's wallet
so let's hope the cost for solar
technology goes down
before attempting to build an 81 000
kilometer stretch
how would solar roadways change the
world though
the largest change and the reason behind
creating these solar roads is the
reduction of carbon dioxide
the biggest driver of global climate
change
many roads are currently paved in
asphalt this material
absorbs 80 to 95 percent of the sun's
rays which
increases heat on the road and
surrounding areas
a phenomenon called the urban heat
island effect
switching over to solar roads would
reduce this effect
creating cooler roadways and cooler
cities
as these solar roads stretched over more
of the globe
the coal industry would have to shutter
its doors and
we would need less petroleum for asphalt
production
many people would lose their jobs
governments
would need to create programs to retool
the workers
for the growing demand of solar road
construction
then there's the roads themselves to
build these roads
solar panels are placed between layers
of glass
silicon rubber and concrete
this makes for a slippery road
especially during rain or snow
the roads would need a durable coating
to create traction
and that coating would have to be safe
for the environment and
humans or would we develop
improved car tires from another material
to
better grip road surfaces another route
is to create smart solar roads these
roads would include
technology to keep their surface above
freezing
charge electric cars as they drive and
use leds for
bright road surface markings there
are a lot of roadblocks for this new
technology
cost material and safety being the big
ones
but is it worth it to invest in research
and development
in 2014 the netherlands built a solar
bike path
this 70 meter bike path generated
000 kilowatt hours in other words
the solar bike path could power a small
household for
one year talk about recycling your
carbon footprint in a powerful way
despite current limitations solar paved
roads
might still be a possibility in our
future
though there are other ways to use solar
panel technology
for renewable energy why ground are
thinking earthbound
there's a lot of open space up on our
moon
is it possible to install solar panels
on the moon
and for us to access that energy
well that's a story for another
what if